[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHMIDT: Welcome
to Google.
STEPHEN COLBERT: A pleasure
to be here in the flesh.
I watch you guys online all the
time, really great show.
It's slow, but you just never
know where the plot's going.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Jim DeMint
has just announced--
STEPHEN COLBERT: Jim
DeMint, yes, yeah.
Jim's a friend, but go ahead.
ERIC SCHMIDT: He's just
announced that he's retiring.
And it occurs to me that you
might want to-- you're from
South Carolina originally,
I think?
STEPHEN COLBERT: Yes, I am.
I'm from South Carolina,
the palmetto state.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You might want
to run for Senate.
STEPHEN COLBERT: No, I do not
want to run for Senate.
I want Nikki Haley to just
appoint me to senate.
That's the great thing, people
are asking me, are you going
to run for Senate?
And like, no, why
would you run?
She just gets to
say, it's you.
So, yeah, while I'm honored by
what you're implying and by
the groundswell that
I've felt.
But obviously, that's something
I have to take up
with my family and my pastor
before I decide whether to
take that position.
Is there another question,
Senator?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Do you think
Bill O'Reilly would be a
better choice?
STEPHEN COLBERT: He's not
in South Carolina.
But he's a very talented man.
And I sincerely admire his
broadcasting abilities.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But, you
know, you're locked
in a deathly battle.
STEPHEN COLBERT: With
Bill right now?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes.
STEPHEN COLBERT: Oh,
you mean over the--
ERIC SCHMIDT: The book.
STEPHEN COLBERT: Over
the book, exactly.
Bill's got a book called
"Killing Kennedy." And I
admire his obsession with
terrible things happening to
presidents.
He's got "Killing Lincoln,"
"Killing Kennedy," "Sodomizing
Coolidge"--
that's a kids' book.
He was on John Stewart's show.
And he said his next book is
going to be called "Killing
Colbert." And it broke my
character's heart so much to
hear Papa Bear say that.
So we launched operation Killing
"Killing Kennedy."
Where I'm just telling my
audience out there--
I'm not telling you
to buy my book.
I don't want to abuse
the relationship.
But I'm just reminding them,
if you're going to buy my
book-- and you are--
if you're going to buy
my book, just do
it all in one week.
So we can leapfrog at least
one of his killing books.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Which week do you
want us to all your book?
STEPHEN COLBERT: Right
now, as we speak.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Right now.
This week.
STEPHEN COLBERT: Right now.
Go right now.
Go to a local bookstore, a
small bookstore, a big
bookstore, online,
ERIC SCHMIDT: Your book
is on Google Play.
STEPHEN COLBERT: What
does that mean?
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
our online store.
You're going to end up
being your best--
STEPHEN COLBERT: I know
all about Google Play.
Really?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes.
STEPHEN COLBERT: So
go to Google Play.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Absolutely.
STEPHEN COLBERT: And
what happens there?
ERIC SCHMIDT: People are going
to pay you lots of money to
buy your book.
STEPHEN COLBERT: Well, then
it's a wonderful service.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Excellent.
STEPHEN COLBERT: So you
go there, and you
can click on it?
It's like going to, it's like
that one that's named after a
rainforest.
You go to that one.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You click
on it and you get it?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes.
It's the competitor
to the rainforest.
STEPHEN COLBERT: I don't
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
further more--
STEPHEN COLBERT: Because
we got to preserve that
rainforest.
We got to stop making books
out of that rainforest.
Do you get a physical
book from you guys?
Or is it all the ebook thing?
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
an ebook thing.
STEPHEN COLBERT: It's
only ebook?
ERIC SCHMIDT: You can
get a physical, too.
We'll sell you one of those.
STEPHEN COLBERT: You will?
ERIC SCHMIDT: We'll get it
through your publisher.
STEPHEN COLBERT: Good.
ERIC SCHMIDT: At list
price, no less.
STEPHEN COLBERT: What?
At less price?
ERIC SCHMIDT: At list price.
STEPHEN COLBERT:
At list price?
At list price.
So go to Google + for no deal.
If you're willing to pay list--
which you should.
Because if you pay list price
they include more book.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Understood.
STEPHEN COLBERT: I'm not
going to give this
stuff away for free.
"America Again, Re-Becoming
the Greatness We Never
Weren't." Has to be written this
way, because clearly our
country's in trouble, yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
STEPHEN COLBERT: OK, you can
tell because I am the country.
And I'm all beaten up
on the cover here.
We want to re-become the
greatness, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
STEPHEN COLBERT: All right.
But if I said we never were,
then that would mean America
was never great, right?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes.
STEPHEN COLBERT: But if I said
that we presently aren't, that
would mean I'm criticizing
America, which you
mustn't ever do.
Therefore, it's America again,
re-becoming the greatness we
never weren't.
Unless you've got something
bad to say about
America, Eric Schmidt.
Do you have something bad
to say about America?
Because let me know.
Because I'm sure all these
people and YouTube would love
to know what problem you've got
with the US of A, mister.
Because I don't.
And I've proven it with a title
that makes no sense.
ERIC SCHMIDT: In this doctrine
of American exceptionalism,
right, which is I think what
the book is actually about.
STEPHEN COLBERT: It is about and
that's the first chapter.
It is the thesis statement,
American exceptionalism.
Rules don't apply to us.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK, so if that's
true, how does America become
great if the rules don't
apply to us?
STEPHEN COLBERT: Buy the book.
Every chapter tells us how to
return to what we already know
is the right thing, is to
reject socialism, reject
collectivism, and
go with the gut.
We even have a chapter
just on food.
Why America is the crispest,
crunchiest, most corn-fed
nation on earth.
And if you are what you eat,
then just put a stick up our
butt, and we're all corn
dogs walking around.
ERIC SCHMIDT: In preparing for
this book did you study the
amendments to the
Constitution?
And did you have any opinions
about the amendments?
STEPHEN COLBERT: I always have
opinions about the amendments
of the Constitution.
I mean everybody's got their
top, like what their top 10
amendments are.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Do you have
a top you like?
STEPHEN COLBERT: My number
one would probably
be the Second Amendment.
And my number two
would probably
be the First Amendment.
And then probably my third
would be the Seventh.
My fourth would be the 10th.
Fifth would be the Ninth.
Sixth would be the Eighth.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Is everybody
writing this down?
STEPHEN COLBERT: Yeah, get this
down, because I don't
have a rationale behind it.
No, but there's nothing about
the Constitution in the book.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But the
Constitution allows
this book to be.
It's free speech.
STEPHEN COLBERT: Well,
sure, no, no, no--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEPHEN COLBERT: The Second
Amendment allows
this book to exist.
ERIC SCHMIDT: The First
Amentment--
STEPHEN COLBERT: Because if
anybody stopped-- no, no, the
Second Amendment.
Because if anybody stopped me
from publishing this book, I
would shoot them in the face.
Do you understand me?
Are we clear?
ERIC SCHMIDT: That's
very, very clear.
STEPHEN COLBERT: It does, the
Second Amendment guarantees
all other liberties.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: Why did comedy,
kind of, become your
thing, do you think?
Or did comedy kind
of pick you?
STEPHEN COLBERT: Well, that's
a nice way of putting it.
That's a nice way
of putting it.
I would say, I can't under
emphasize how important comedy
has been to my life.
And how important certain
opportunities that came along
to my life, and many of them
seem sort of accidental.
I went to college
to be an actor.
But an actor, actor.
I wore black and
I had a beard.
I was like, let me share my
misery with you, you know.
And then I accidentally met some
people from Second City
and took some classes there and
got invited to audition.
And accidentally, just sort of a
happy accident, fell in with
some great people.
And I quit Second
City four times.
I kept on returning
to doing comedy.
And I was backstage one night.
And this is really the thing
that made the decision for me.
Somebody was on stage, and they
were supposed to do a
very simple blackout.
A blackout is a very short--
it's got one joke, and then
the lights go out.
This is Second City.
It's a pace keeper
for the show.
She goes out there and the
blackout is this, she goes--
you're supposed to say, I'd like
to do a song for you now.
Welcome to the No Exit Cafe.
I'd like to do a song
for you right now.
A song for the whales.
And then you tune up your
guitar for a long time.
This is a song for the whales.
And then you go--
[IMITATING WHALES]
[CLICKING]
STEPHEN COLBERT: It's
very simple.
You do whistle and clicks
and everything.
It's fine.
Not a great laugh.
But it works every time.
She goes out there to do it.
I'd like to do a song
for you right now.
She just goes into her whistling
and her clicking.
And we're backstage waiting
to go on for the next
scene, me and Dave.
And we said, it's not
getting any laughs.
This is fool proof.
No laughs at all.
What's going on?
Something's wrong.
And then she goes, oh, I forgot
it's song for whales.
And we burst into laughter
backstage.
And we threw our arms around
each other in the
agony of her failure.
And just laughing, we fell
like a collapsing teepee.
We just fell to the ground.
And Dave's feet went out
onto stage, like this.
As we held each other
like lovers.
The most intimate, joyful
experience at her pain, that
we all knew.
And she could hear it happen,
and the audience
could see our feet.
And she started laughing
at how wonderfully
she had just failed.
And I thought at that moment,
this is what I want.
If failure of this scale can
cause this much joy for any
one, then this is the healthiest
thing that I could
do with the rest of my life.
And I will do nothing else.
And I've never looked back
from that moment.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHMIDT: Stephen Colbert,
thank you very much.
STEPHEN COLBERT: Thank you.